♪ And you said my life was tragic ♪
♪ Respectful in the game ♪
♪ I guarantee you the name ♪
♪ It's written that I knew the work ♪
♪ and everything will change ♪
♪ Sipping tea, help the field ♪
♪ Yeah, that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient, hella
tricky if I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with Garyvee ♪
♪ With your positivity, ye eh ♪
- Good morning world.
How are you?
Hope everybody is super duper well.
This is Tea With GaryVee
on a Monday, June 29.
Big shout out to Zeus MG on Twitch.
Rich Porter, what's good?
Tony Timur in the building.
Jerry Garcia, not the, but...
Biggie Jay, good to see you on Facebook.
Professor Kevin great to see too.
And Hope on Facebook, and see Andre.
Cut Nuts on Facebook,
Dion Woo on Twitter good to see you.
Good to see everybody, everybody.
Where's LinkedIn at?
Comments only, there we go.
Hezron Nazario holding
it down for LinkedIn.
Dustin, what's good?
How are you?
- Good.
- Good weekend?
- Yeah, Very good weekend.
- It makes me happy.
You bought sports cards, any Pokimane?
- I got one for free.
It's a...
- That's nice.
Well, Darren Fox.
- Yeah.
- I'm big on that.
Somebody is a fan of yours
and they sent it to you?
- Yeah, it was a previous
guest, John Tory.
- I like that.
- He said he had a bunch,
and then he already made his money back.
So he wanted to give me one.
I was like, "Oh, that's
awesome." (chuckles)
- You listened to me early now.
- So, shout out to him.
- Shout out to him for right.
I mean, kindness is always a good move.
Friday's sports card Tea
With GaryVee was fun.
I really wanna do like a, 10 hour.
(laughs)
Do it so fast. (snaps)
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, let's get into the show.
Let's do it.
Hope everybody is super good.
Morning, morning, morning.
Oh, we got two.
- Good morning?
- I love it, two people plus one.
(laughs)
Hi, Jean, hi girls.
- That's a good one.
- Hi Gary.
- Good to see you.
- Yeah, good to see you too.
We met when you were in, Denver.
- I remember, I remember
coming to your office.
It was a great time.
You did a fantastic job.
- Oh, thanks, yeah, good to see you.
And this is Angela.
She's my co-founder.
What's happening this morning?
How are you?
- All good, it's really
nice to see you ladies.
- Yeah, awesome.
- Thank you.
So, I just want to jump into our question.
I know we have a few minutes.
So we're putting on
the Women's Social Media
Days Summit, tomorrow,
which is Social Media day, June 30th.
And sometimes we get pushback
from business owners.
They're like, social media
is not that effective,
or maybe we don't get as many conversions
off of social media.
So kind of, basically getting a lot of,
not a lot, but sometimes
we get pushed back from--
- You get pushed back,
or I'll say a couple things.
One, a lot of businesses are right
when they push back against social,
because they are asking
the social media experts
or companies for short
term sales conversion,
and the social media people
are actually not hearing them.
- Aah.
- And they're talking about,
the multidimensional aspect of social,
which is, it is definitely
a communications portal, PR.
it is unbelievably a brand
play, like television.
The amount of money
that a lot of businesses
spend on social is so small.
And they're looking for
miracles from social
that doesn't come from print or Google.
And then, most people in
social not good at selling.
One of the things that I
think makes VaynerMedia strong
and what makes me strong,
with like Empathy, or like K-Swiss,
or whatever it is.
I really understand how
to do creative and media.
We understand how to
do creative and media.
My organizations understand
how to do creative and media
to actually create short term results.
Many social media people
only take on community management
and some random organic content,
which has no prayer to create
short term, short term sales conversions,
which leads to the mass
cynicism of businesses.
We are in the early stages of social,
these first, 10 years.
And what that means is,
you have a lot of hucksters
that come on and try to ride the wave.
And aren't actually good
at servicing clients
and helping people grow their business.
Make false promises,
and more importantly,
don't even understand
the question that the
business is asking them.
And so ,I actually have a lot of empathy
for a lot of businesses that
struggle with social media,
because the person that's
trying to provide the results,
9 or 10 times, didn't hear it,
or bullshitted their way to get the money,
but had no chance of delivering.
And I think that's the real
punchline to be honest.
But can you create short term results?
Of course you can.
That's why so many brands
have been built on Instagram and Facebook.
Of course you can.
But it actually takes real talent.
I can play basketball,
but it doesn't mean I can play in the NBA.
(chuckles)
And I think right now
we have a lot of people
selling social media
that are not ready for the NBA.
I am the other hand, I'm,
fucking, LeBron James.
- So it's definitely a
more longterm place really.
And I think maybe that's a
misconception in the marketplace,
that a lot of business owners think that,
"Hey, social media, let's get it done.
"And tomorrow I'm gonna be a millionaire."
So I think that's--
- Well, I mean, anytime anybody.
I mean, that's my
biggest concern right now
with sports cards.
I'm talking about it so much.
- Yeah.
It's, nothing's easy.
Everything takes education,
executions, patients.
On the flip side,
I don't wanna gloss over this.
If somebody gave me, $10,000,
and said, "The number one thing
I want, Gary, is sales."
I know how to run ads on
Facebook and Instagram,
and YouTube pre-roll to make that happen.
I might not have enough
money in that, 10,000
to make content and run media,
to create the sales that
that person anticipates.
And so that's why you have
to end up to a conversation.
But most people just
wanna take on the money.
- So really, it's all about framing then,
when you're having the
conversation with the client.
- And asking questions
- Right.
Setting expectations for real.
Right, this is why so many
people watching right now,
whether they're watching
live on Tea With Garyvee,
or when they watch this clip
on YouTube or Instagram.
The reason they turn so many clients,
is they just want the dollars,
but they only get three
months worth of dollars
and get fired.
The reason I've been
able to build something
from zero to $200 million in revenue is,
we keep clients, because we're
not full of shit upfront.
We really, calibrate what the request is.
And then we go and execute.
- Right.
- I like that, I like that.
So, I think that that's
really important, Jean,
as we have our Social Media Day tomorrow,
is to really talk about the frame, right?
And setting that expectation,
even for solopreneurs
that do the social media themselves.
- Let me give you another example
that may help a lot of people.
A lot of people are paying,
$3,000 a month for PR,
and then are paying,
2,000 for social media
and not getting results from social media.
And they're mad at social media.
Meanwhile, social media oftentimes
can outperform traditional
PR, every day of the week.
But this agency, or the person,
or the internal person,
didn't frame social
as a PR comms thing,
they framed it as a sales thing.
Which again, it can easily be done.
90% are not good at the
combination of media and creative.
They're good at the creative part,
the organic part,
the community management part.
Which services as PR or brand.
Again, you have a lot of B2B businesses
that will buy a banner
at a little league stadi
or buy a by a booth at a
convention that they don't convert,
but they do it because they have to do it.
It's the cost of entry
to be in the industry.
Cost of entry to be in
the industry of the world,
is to have a social media account.
Going hard, LinkedIn, Facebook, Twitter.
- And love.
- Any business that isn't
spending two to $5,000 a month,
just to keep the lights on,
on creative, just for brand.
Realizing that people search.
I mean, to me, it's more
important than your website.
People search to see
what you're doing there,
but most small social media
individuals and agencies,
and internal operators,
don't position it as a comms branding
cost of entry in 2020,
for consumer respect and conversion.
Too many businesses are in
transactional mode, sales mode.
"We spent, 2,000, how
many sales did I get?"
But they didn't realize
that one of the sales they got that month
was 'cause somebody went to
their Instagram and Twitter,
and saw that they're real.
- Wow, I love it.
- Yeah, that's true.
But, I mean, it's just so many times
that clients really expect like,
"Oh, I need the sales." (chuckles)
By the way, they do need the sales.
And by the way,
anybody who wants to build
a monster, like I did,
have to be incredible
at the ability to drive sales
through Facebook media
and Instagram media,
and LinkedIn media,
and Google pre-roll, YouTube,Content.
TikTok's real.
In fact, for marketing is real.
It's real, it's way harder
than putting out, happy
Flag Day on your Twitter.
- That's true. (chuckles)
- And that goes back
to the analogy I made.
- Yeah, it's all inclusive, I think.
I think that--
- Well, that's why I'm
obsessed with it, Angela.
- I know. (chuckles)
- It's the most, 360 thing in marketing.
TV is great for brand,
but YouTube and Facebook
videos can do brand,
and have a link right there,
and create no friction for
the conversion of sale.
Paying a PR person, $4,000 a month
to get you pressed,
when you can get pressed just by posting.
It's the most encompassing,
360 way to do marketing.
- I mean, I guess it's just
all managing expectations--
(chuckles) Yeah absolutely.
- Thank you guys.
I wish you well tomorrow.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
Yeah, we really appreciate you,
and appreciate your time.
- Thanks Angela.
- Thank you.
- Thanks so much.
Talk to you soon, bye bye.
Now, I kinda just wanna rock
my hair like this today.
I've been up for about an hour and a half.
Big shout out to, Lord in New Orleans.
Thank you for that favorite show.
Shout out DJ Yasmina.
I appreciate you.
Mildred, what's good?
I missed you too, Ryan X.
Lurks k. what's good.
I agree, B. Hicks.
I like this look.
All right, let's keep it going.
Jordan, what's good?
- How are you?
Not too much, mate.
It's very late here, in
Melbourne, nearly 12.
Hey, I sent you a link ages ago.
We never got to meet up and in Melbourne,
due to some bad weather.
But I'm wondering if you ever watched that
bold and bankrupt video
on, Babruysk, your hometown.
- I don't know.
Can you make sure Dustin gets the URL,
so I definitely see it this weekend.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thank you so much.
We'll send it, for sure.
So my question for you,
it's been very interesting
here in Australia
due to COVID, obviously.
Our government has,
basically, given a few businesses,
and we've been one of
those that is quite lucky.
That essentially we've been
giving a cashflow boost
of the equivalent of a
month's worth of sales.
- Stimulus cheque.
- Pardon?
A stimulus cheque.
- Essentially, essentially.
- Yeah.
- And, look, I think that the thing
that I find most interesting about you,
is that, it's not just your ability
to understand the tension,
but to allocate capital.
I mean, you've built
this vertical company.
You've got media assets, creative.
The media side of the
business as well, production.
I guess I'm curious from your side
for you as a younger entrepreneur,
when you first started VaynerMedia.
What were the smartest investments?
Was it in people?
Or was it acquiring--
- Jordan, you literally took
the words out of my mouth.
It was in, David Xang,
it was in Marcus Chris astic,
It was in Joe Whitmarsh, Phil Toronto.
It was in humans, Mat Cinema.
It was humans.
Kelly McCarthy in Tennessee.
(lip buzzing) There's just
nothing close to the humans.
It was the humans.
- Yeah, and--
- But you have to understand,
that's 'cause I like managing
people and I like people.
So the answer is not for everybody.
Some people are quite
introverted and awkward,
and don't enjoy the process of humans.
And for them, the answer
would have been technology.
For a lot of different companies,
the answer was, "We hired four engineers,
we barely talked to each other remotely.
"We build this awesome product
and that started it."
For me, my great strength
is the enjoyment of people,
the understanding of people,
the compassion for people.
Even when people are mean and angry
and judgmental of me,
even then, I don't get triggered.
I'm so grateful,
I mean, I kiss my parents
on a face for this.
I kiss my immigrant circumstances
in the face for this.
My genuine, genuine love for people.
I mean, right now, we're
going through a time
in the world where,
in the U.S. and many other
places, enormous fractions.
Me verse you, you verse them.
And to me, my great strength is,
finding that common ground
of compassion, empathy.
Genuinely caring about your fellow man
and trying to act on it.
Which is always very challenging
through a business world.
'Cause you have business
realities as well.
But for me it was people, so yes.
- So, we're in this early stage now,
obviously running an agency,
we've got probably five or six staff.
And, I guess I was curious,
I tried to jump back three, four years ago
to some of your videos
around your first hires.
Who were the smartest?
- It's family and friends,
family, and friends.
- Good.
- I'm a big family and friends guy.
- Why?
- 'Cause it's different.
'Cause it's stickier.
- Do you think it's a trust thing?
- Yeah, of course.
- Even if they're not experienced.
- Yeah.
Yeah, of course, It's family.
- Hmm, 'cause we're having that right now.
We're hiring for different roles
that we haven't hired for in the past.
And, I lack of that--
- Let me jump in, I apologize.
- Yeah.
- One of the things that I had,
was I knew the role.
- Yeah.
- When I was hiring these kids,
my brother's friends from college,
that's the answer, in high school.
Or hardcore fans of, VaynerMedia TV
that I knew for five or six years, online.
When I was hiring for them,
the big key was, I knew
how to do all those jobs.
Thus, I could judge if
they were progressing.
If you don't know the jobs,
you're in more of a
pickle in that scenario.
- Yeah, well, I mean,
I've been doing pretty much everything.
Strategy, sales and marketing
for about three years.
Two years maybe three years.
And my co-founder does
all creative production.
And I don't have an industry background,
so it's been very interesting.
- Me neither.
- Yeah, well.
- You don't have to have the experience,
you just have to know them.
- Yeah, well, the hardest thing is,
like you said,
is I was deliberating and
speaking to another owner
of probably the biggest
independent agency here.
And he was like,
"You really need to be particular
about the role it is that you're hiring.
Because people are just
not, they're not you.
They're not going to have the same passion
and be able to do all the
things how I do them--
- And they shouldn't.
And owners, and bosses, and CEOs
should not hold their
employees accountable
to that same level of passion, hours.
Cause they're not being
compensated the same way.
- He believes that,
the first hire that he
should always go to,
if he was to pick account managers,
strategists and creative,
the first should always
be account manager,
because they'll pay for the other two.
- I understand that.
And I see a lot of validity in that.
I think the first hire
is the single person
that reverse engineers
the founder, CEO, leader.
So for me, that was an admin.
- Yeah.
- Because, because that
was my weakest link
of not wanting to do that kind of work.
So I think you hire a...
and by the way,
I don't know what that
gentleman did for a living.
If he was a creative or what have you.
But if you yourself are an account person,
potentially the first hire
that matters is a creative.
- Yeah, well, I've told them
the wise decision was a strategist.
'Cause I'm not a marketer per se.
And I come from that account
management, sales background.
But--
- A sales person matters.
I've seen shops that
start with five people
that can do something,
but not one of them
could sell a fucking
ice cream in a desert,
and they go out of business.
(chuckles)
I think these are all self-awareness games
for all of us out here.
- Yeah, do you,
if you think back to that
time in those first days,
how long until you realistically realize
that you could stop working
in that real nitty gritty of day-to-day.
Where you're just constantly involved in--
- I'm still in it now.
Yeah, but, you know what I mean
when you're, you're literally
the account manager,
the sales person, the marketer--
As soon as soon as you can afford it.
- Yeah.
- That was about two years for us.
- Yeah, it's exciting though.
It's exciting--
- Yeah, there's nothing
more fun than building.
- Yeah.
Jordan, thank you so much, brother.
I wish you well.
- Thank you.
I'll make sure I check out that video.
- Cheers, thank you.
- Cheers.
Some thoughtful shit.
Some thoughtful business shit here
to start the real like operations.
A little bit more people
that have started a business.
A little bit then entrepreneurship.
I like that.
Little nice twist.
Let's keep it going.
- Oh my God, hi Gary.
- Hi Miriam, how are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
I'm sorry, I can't actually process
that this is real right now.
- I'm thankful, where are you from?
- I'm from Australia.
I live in Adelaide.
So I'm one stay over.
- And doing well.
- Oh thank goodness.
'Cause some people really hate my city
and they make fun of it a lot.
- Why?
- I don't know.
Apparently there's nothing to do here.
It is what it is.
- They're serious wine in Adelaide,
so I know it well.
- Yes!
- Garyvee, okay, Adelaide
has won the Australia game.
Thank you so much for that.
- You're welcome.
- I'm sorry, well, okay,
I'm really nervous.
So, first of all, I just
want to say thank you.
This show has become
a massive part of my life
over the last few months.
Pretty much since it started.
So I'm a digital artist.
And pretty much since it started,
I've just been making drawings
based on things that you
say throughout the episodes.
And I've been posting
them on social media.
And it's just honestly brought in
some of the best people
I've interacted with.
And it's just taught me a lot
about what I'm capable of,
and the type, content
creation and things like that.
So I just wanna say thank you,
because without COVID or lockdown,
we wouldn't have this show.
And, yeah, I wouldn't be on that.
- It's awesome.
- So my question,
could I just give a little
bit of context to it?
- Please.
- So I have endometriosis,
I don't know if you know that illness.
- I do, I do.
- Okay.
- So, this year has been
a little bit rocky for me.
I basically dropped out of university,
because I had a bunch of
health issues come up,
and I had to have a surgery.
And I was pretty much
failing all my classes.
It was just really hard
to kind of do the health thing,
and do my university stuff as well.
- Yeah, of course, I'm sorry to hear that.
- No, it's okay, it's okay. (chuckles)
But what's ironic is
through all of that Olivia
and then T.
All of this has been one
of the biggest things
that has helped me to be honest.
But at the moment,
I'm in this really weird situation
where I don't know
whether I should go back to university,
or if I take a break.
And I know your opinions
on college and that.
- And, listen, just to take the platform,
my opinions on college works for some,
it just doesn't work for a lot more people
than the world has accepted.
- Yeah.
- Especially people that take on debt,
and get a degree that gives them no ROI,
the second they walk out of school.
That is incredibly scary to me.
That's a very big U.S. problem.
Obviously other parts of the world
have education paid for in different ways.
- Yeah.
- But I also think it's about happiness.
I mean, I always think about why.
Why do you go to college?
Do you go to college to people like,
"Well, Gary, it's not
just about the degree,
it's about the social growth."
I'm like, "Well, you can go
backpacking through Europe.
- Yeah.
- You could be around young people
and not pay for the
education part, you know?
- So I feel like my attitude towards it
has changed over the last couple of years.
I've dropped out twice.
So I dropped out in my second year.
I took the whole year
off for endometriosis.
That was the year I was diagnosed.
And that year,
was the year I basically
taught myself digital art.
So I kinda went completely
opposite direction.
And now I have this thing
that I absolutely love
and I do it every single day.
And I try to put myself
out there on social media
and everything like that.
But I feel like my head is
always in true directions.
Like I have this creative side
and then I have this academic side.
But what comes with the academic side
is like the literal pain
experience. (chuckles)
- Well, I mean, just think about that.
- I know.
- Just re-watch this.
- Yeah.
- Like even if it was, 1975,
when colleges are, or why it
was extraordinarily strong.
And you could get a job immediately,
and you couldn't get one without it.
And it paid for itself
based on the cost of the degree.
Even then, if it's
literally brought you pain,
the answer is,
(laughs)
it's not a good idea.
I mean, I think, at some point here,
people are gonna realize
happiness over money.
At some point it's going to happen,
I just believe it.
And it's gonna flip the world upside down.
And I think a lot of the things I debate
and think about,
will come into focus during that time.
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
so, this is one of the biggest reasons
I started listening to you.
You're, honestly, I'm so sorry,
I'm really nervous at the moment.
I'm so excited to be here.
- Thank you.
- Your content, honestly, changed my life.
Because, I feel like I've,
I tend to judge myself
a lot, unnecessarily.
I really don't need to be like that.
And I find it really hard
to snap out of that sometimes.
And I just, honestly, turn you on
I listened to your
content day in, day out.
Creating stuff based on your content
is one of, like I said it before,
but, honestly, it's just one
of the most positive things
that I've done with my time.
Sorry, I was just gonna say,
- No, its okay.
- No, no, no.
- I'm why I'm wildly
flattered, keep going.
- I Just wanted to ask,
I know you talk a lot about,
when you do or don't do something,
you don't judge yourself for it.
And, I just want your perspective.
Because I tend to tie my self-esteem up
in a lot of these things.
And, what is your advice
for letting go of that completely
- By focusing on realizing.
It's almost by muting the accolades
more than negativity.
I think what's really worked for me,
is that humility, leads to the ability
to not have your self-esteem wrapped up
in the win or the loss.
To me, it was about,
when things were working for me,
not thinking that I was
special or better than anybody.
- Yeah.
- It was actually in the humility
that I found peace.
- Yeah.
- I don't come off as a humble person
'cause I talk loud,
I'm aggressive, I'm competitive.
I like sports, I like competition.
But in my real kinda core,
I don't think I'm special
in any shape or form.
I really genuinely don't.
I genuinely, genuinely do not.
- Yeah.
- And because of that,
when people say you're a genius,
or you saved my life,
or all this, you're the GOAT.
Tt feels amazing.
I'm so grateful.
It's so nice.
However, I don't take it to heart.
I don't begin to believe it.
And so what that also means,
is when somebody says,
"You're full of shit, you suck,
you're the worst."
It allows me to not get torn down.
And so I just kinda stay in the middle.
Like to me,
I think a lot about being
a hundred years old.
And do I care about what anonymous person
or even my cousin thought
of me at, 100 or at 75
of being terminally diagnosed.
I mean, you've already had a health scare.
You can really use this.
I think you have to think back
to the judgment you could had growing up.
That doesn't mean demonize your parents
or your circumstance.
It means just understand it,
'cause they probably have the same thing
happening to them.
- Yeah.
- And really just reframing.
So I talk about positivity
and practicality
into your ears.
- Yeah.
- The reason you're in a better place,
is you've been listening to
a lot of what I'm saying,
which I'm grateful.
And it sounds like it's
bringing you some value.
I mean, ultimately when you realize
you don't matter that much,
it is actually liberating.
- (chuckles) Yeah, I agree, yeah.
- That's how I do it.
That's the truth.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Between that, and realizing
what's important to me,
like, who cares if my business failed
or my post didn't do well,
or people think I'm a bad guy.
- Yeah.
- Like my parents are healthy.
And as long as that's,
simply just keep it
simple and keep it humble.
Keep it simple, keep it humble.
And you will watch your happiness explode.
- Yeah.
- That doesn't mean stay complacent.
I'm the fucking most hungry,
ambitious person you'll meet.
But, I really, really, just
keep it simple and humble.
- Yeah, that's awesome.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- Thanks Miriam, hope you're welcome.
I wish you well.
- I'm so sorry, could you
follow me on Instagram?
Because, I make a lot of artwork
and it's, I just wanted
you to see some of them.
Actually, wait, you shed some of it.
I'm so sorry, Gary.
My mind has completely blanked.
- Probably I wasn't following.
I'm on it now.
- Okay, It's absolutely fine.
- No, no I'm in.
And I love it.
(chuckles)
- Yeah, those building drawings
were based on how to build
the tallest building.
And it's just those, you know.
- You're at 519.
Let's see what the Vayner
nation does for you
over the next hour.
- Oh my God.
I just want to thank you so much, Gary.
Yeah, thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(clicks) Everybody follow
this wonderful lady.
We'll talk soon, bye, bye.
- Bye, bye. (chuckles)
- Let's keep it rocking.
Mondo, how are you?
You're on mute.
- Good man, how's it going? (chuckles)
- It's going well.
Really nice to meet you.
Good, Gary, my name is max.
- Max.
- Based in 2016, I'll
quickly kinda run through.
And first off, thanks for
all the content you do.
- Of course.
- It was about 2016, I put together,
what is essentially a
neon business, neon signs.
In fact, we actually did
put the Twitch studio
with your signature in green.
- Yes, yes, yes, thank you.
- That's a new use for that.
I actually walked into your office,
in the shipping depot
and actually drop it onto it.
I don't know, Gary.
How they let me up actually.
So, its actually how it got up there.
So, it's kind of fun,
taking it on a subway
and driving down there.
Those are kind of the fun hustle things
that get things put through.
But basically, I wanted to make something
that I kinda knew enough
about the business.
And it's kinda one of
those tricky businesses.
It's a little sticky.
It's a hundred years old,
hasn't changed at all,
but has a lot of creativity
and a lot of value kind
of in the sense that,
people are actually
working in these fires.
And so what I did,
is I just created kind of a media side
to all of that.
What essentially happened to neon,
it became almost like a
used car-salesman approach.
I've got some signs, I can
get it up there for you.
And I just felt like
the template was so old.
And so, I tried to bring
in this other idea,
kinda artistic side, the creative side.
So, my question is that,
15 years being in New York city,
I have now moved to Louisville, Kentucky.
And the operation, is
really still just me.
kind of running everything, the media,
putting everything out.
We have a podcast the only
podcast about neon signs.
And that kind of keeps
view, over 80 episodes now.
Basically putting other
artists on other shops
that actually had no voice.
kind of limited to that
they're only doing,
kind of like they're in their little town.
But now, because of Instagram,
that's all kinda shifted, which is great.
They all kind of know each other now.
- Of course.
- And there's this huge landscape.
So, I'm trying to figure out
what are the best ways
to basically being connected,
and COVID kinda limiting and all that.
What would you do,
transitioning from a
place like, New York City,
where everything's kind
of quickly happening.
A lot of businesses and everything.
Everyone's kinda transitioning,
and what is essential to them.
So there's kinda been a slow
down, I think, naturally,
'cause these things kind
of do come up sometimes.
What to spend on as far as businesses.
But it was consumer, direct to consumer,
to ship the neon signs.
So, it shipped throughout the nation.
So, a lot of business in L.A.
and a lot of things in New
York that we used to do.
What would be some of
the things you would do
to transition to the Midwest?
- Well, I mean, are you unable to ship
the neon signs to, New York and L.A.?
- No, they can go anywhere.
Anywhere in the nation, we ship neon.
- So what's the concern.
You mean more of some of the local,
low hanging fruit in New York,
is stronger than in Louisville.
AKA, like dropping
something off in my office,
- Not necessarily that,
but I just think,
trying to get the word out that,
we're also here now.
We've done such a good job
of putting out information in New York,
and kinda Louisville.
- And have you separated that
from the fact that neon signs,
becomes one of the line items
that disappears during
an economic turndown?
- I think that's some of it too,
like how to adjust that.
- It definitely is.
I think during these times,
you just have to, weather the storm.
Like everything you were doing
to get a certain amount of signs sold,
you almost have to do
twice as much just to keep.
It's kind of what I did both downturns
at the wine business, right?
It took so much more
effort in April, 2000,
'cause of the stock market crash.
And then September, 2001,
'cause of 9/11.
It took me so much effort
in, 2000, 2001, 2002
to basically be even
at the level of, 1999,
even though when we were growing.
Because it was tough.
And then 2008, forget it.
I mean, one of the first
things that disappeared
was $60 wine.
And so, I think you have to realize
that, 100% reality around.
It's gonna take you
more podcasts episodes,
more Facebook, Louisville,
Local advertising.
Because now when you get in front of,
200 people, in Louisville,
a year ago, 13 of them
would have bought a sign.
Now only three will,
because of the financial
situation and the needs.
I think during these times,
I mean, I think nothing's changed Max.
On like what platforms can work.
Whether that's TikTok,
or LinkedIn, or YouTube.
What's changed, is the
conversion behavior.
I think about it as gaining weight.
If you, during COVID, gained 15 pounds,
when you go back to the gym,
nothing's changed.
You gonna do the same regimen
that was got you into that shape.
The problem is,
it's gonna take longer to
get back to a great place.
'Cause you put on the 15 pounds.
And it's harder.
You're at a practice,
your joints are a little fucked up.
Sometimes when I miss some gym time,
it's like, damn.
Last August to like December,
was probably the weakest timeframe
of my workout in the last five years.
And it was really tough to
get back to the same place.
And I think that's what
people gonna deal with
within the post COVID.
And so more reps is what
you're saying, basically.
Just stay--
- More reps and recognizing
that those reps are not gonna give you
the same returns that they once did,
but you've got to get through, otherwise.
I mean, people like, "Gary that sucks."
I'm like, "Cool, what's the alternative.
Going out of business?"
- Yeah, and it's a cool.
I think It's also like for the one
we did a sign for empathy,
that was up there too.
- Yes, I know.
- You'll see, and it's like,
we just did one for, Tracer and Jonathan.
So that just went up to L.A.
So he's got that over there now.
It's actually at his house.
So that'll be fun.
Hopefully he gets to open up
and guys get to see it back to the office.
- I will check that out.
- So little things like that.
- Yeah, and so all I'd say,
- I think Local, Facebook
and LinkedIn advertising
in the area of Lexington,
will bring you more
dividends than you realize.
So I would really focus on that.
- Okay, thanks Gary.
- Awesome, brother, talk to you soon.
Thanks for all the nice gestures
you've done for being our X.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you, bye, bye.
Let's push, I let the show thoughtful.
Gustavo.
- Hey, how's it going, Gary?
- Very good.
- Man, really excited to be here.
Anyway, so, huge shout out
to your team, Zane, Dustin.
You guys rock, thank you so much.
Hey, that guy, Zubin,
is a beast by the way.
I'm loving that content.
I'm a business owner.
I run a business.
Everything that guy says,
seems to be really,
really well thought out.
So looking forward to that today.
- Leonard Commerce is very strong
and he's very sharp.
- Love it, love it.
Anyways, so, wanna tell you,
you'll get a kick out of this.
You know me.
I'm that guy, used to be in corporate.
Making a hundred K plus.
I left that life.
It just, it wasn't for me.
Wasn't fulfilling, right.
- You were unhappy.
- I came to Mexico.
It's where I'm right now.
It's where I'm basement from.
Started a call center.
I just focused on
helping people that run Facebook ads.
Follow up with their leads.
So we kind of come in,
we're part of an ecosystem
that helps people
convert their leads
into life transfers into appointments.
All that kind of stuff, right?
We hire kids that are here.
Grew up in the U.S..
Came back to Mexico.
That, in every sense of the word
they're American, Gary.
But we kind of help them out.
We get into this job.
And they're working for
companies in the U.S..
Like digital marketing agencies,
real estate agents.
We're focused on real estate.
That's our niche.
That's our area.
So my question to you is this, Gary.
So given that, and
we've grown the company.
I have 50 people working for me right now.
- Congrats.
- Yeah, thank you.
And we have over 300 clients
across the U.S. and Canada.
And we weathered the COVID, right?
I mean, we survived, we're here.
And the number one thing I did was,
in the middle of March, when it got real,
I started going live on Facebook.
I finally followed a lot of your advice.
I had been not wanting to post anything.
I didn't really want to be
the face of the company.
Well, I stopped that in
the middle of March, right.
So, we went down a little bit,
but man, we survived COVID.
And I think we're ready
to thrive right now.
My concern is this, Gary.
As the leader of the company,
I'm like, okay, should we
double down on real estate?
Or is it time to open up to other niches,
because, holy cow, who knows...
What's that?
- Both.
- Both, what do you mean?
- Double down on real estate and expand.
(laughs)
When people expand,
they oftentimes forget the
thing that got them there.
So if you have a hundred beings
to deploy going forward,
make, 70 of those beings go on real estate
'cause it's working.
And you haven't extracted
all the value yet.
- 100%, 100%.
- And then take 30%
and go into flooring, or insurance,
or small business.
Whatever you think is right.
So the answer is, both.
- Both, and Gary,
when you're running an
organization like that,
how do you keep them, I
mean, the focus, right?
'Cause right now,
one of our biggest, strengths
and selling points is,
"Hey, we know real estate.
"We're 100% real estate.
"This is our thing.
"This is what we do."
How would you kind of--
- Change what you say to people--
Hey, Gustavo, you need to work with us.
Now, I know you're in the
hardware store business.
We crush real estate.
That's our origins.
But we take in those nuances,
and we understand the hardware space,
and we think the comms are there.
And then when you talk to, Gustavo,
the real estate guy or Gal, you said.
Hey, Gustavo, look, you need
to go with us in real estate.
That's our origins.
The first three years of my company.
It's still, 90% of our behavior.
We've expanded into insurance
and mutual funds at Wall Street.
But we are real estate.
All of a sudden, just by
delivering it differently,
you're a board.
- I gotcha, and kinda
play that real estate DNA,
But how it applies, like you said,
"The nuances can apply that much."
Which is true.
100% true, by the way.
A lot of principles, (chuckles)
- That's why I'm saying it.
I know it's fucking true.
(laughs) 100%, 100%.
Yeah, I know,
and I think that's
really good advice, Gary.
And on the social,
when I'm putting my content out there,
I'm working in a call center, Gary.
And I've moved the whole
company virtual now.
What does really awesome
content look like,
if your, you know, neon sign, guy, 100%.
I can think,
"Well, that actually could
be really good content."
- Q and A, see it with, Garyvee.
Look, I got fucked up here.
(laughs)
Fucking backlighting.
Nobody gives a fuck about the production.
Everybody gives a fuck
about the substance.
- I gotcha, get great clients,
great partners, great people out here,
that they're looking to learn from.
Actually, we have a lot
of the same buddies.
- Yeah, or just post on,
LinkedIn or Facebook like,
"Who's got questions."
I mean, your fucking
Gustavo in Mexico right now.
You're not a great client or a big dog.
I'm here to bring value,
bring fucking value.
Watch what happens.
- I gotcha, I gotcha.
- Awesome, talk to you.
- I love it.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- Thank you so much.
- Appreciate you, man.
- Look, it's the same old thing for me.
Thank you, Gustavo.
Go ahead, Dustin, go to the next one.
I'm just wrapping up with a thought.
It's same old thing.
I always talk about like,
"Watch what I do, not what I say."
A lot of the answers
are in the fucking way.
I'm just living it.
Thank you, Ivy.
Thank you for that kind post.
Donny, what's good.
- Gary, what's up, man.
Thanks for having me on the show.
- How are you?
- I'm well
- Of course, brother.
Where are you from,
where are you right now?
Pittsburgh, I'm in my car
'cause my roommate's sleeping.
(chuckles) So,
- Tell your roommate to wake the fuck up.
It's fucking 9:39.
- I think he's actually is getting up now.
He's getting ready to go to work.
- Respect, good.
- So, I just wanna know
if you had any advice
for marketing yourself as a voice actor.
- As a voice?
- Actor, voice actor.
- Actor.
- Yep.
- I think one of the things
I would definitely do,
is look at the number one,
animated, YouTube, and Instagram,
and TikTok, animated pieces of content,
and try to be the voice of something.
'Cause you'll get a
huge amount of exposure.
- Yep.
- I'm a pretty big fan of,
with Vaynermedia and with speaking,
with Garyvee, let's call it,
I did a lot of things free early on
to get exposure and leverage.
- That's right, I'm
doing that too right now.
- But be smart.
You have to give away free
where it's actually valuable to you.
What I mean by that is,
you need to reach out to
things like, Gymshark,
and like MOON JUICE.
Like the biggest
companies on social media.
And say, "Hey,"
A lot of times when people go for free,
the reason a lot of people hate free,
is they give three non-strategically.
And they just do it for whoever asks.
But you're not really getting the ex...
It's not free, you're getting exposure
or learnings in return.
- Yep.
- So I'm a very big
fan of doing voiceover.
Podcasts are exploding.
There's a ton of podcast ads.
If you could become a voice
for like, four to five big companies
that are running heavy.
I would go to Spotify.
Literally I'm not joking,
I would download all, 300 top podcasts
on YouTube and Spotify.
Sit down for a week, listen to them all.
Figure out which companies
are advertising the most on podcasts,
and then call, reach out to them,
and then offer it for, free.
AKA, you're gonna get massive exposure.
And all of a sudden,
you're like a voice that
we'll all recognize.
And kind of like, Moviefone,
or the guidance in a dark place,
in front of the trailers.
- Yeah, I kinda specialize
in like character voice.
Like really weird voice.
So I don't know.
- So the animation idea
sits with you well?
- Yeah, when we first
started quarantining.
I started making Facebook, Instagram,
LinkedIn, TikTok, I'm
on everything, Twitch.
And I started taking random
video clips off the internet,
and just record,
recording whatever
voiceover I come up with
and just post it.
And, I ran Facebook (indistinct) videos.
It went pretty well on three months.
So, it got me up to
like 7,000 on Facebook,
Instagram I'm nowhere.
I gotta figure out how to advertise on
those other platforms.
But yeah, right now I'm
just taking videos--
- I think LinkedIn,
Donny, you're chopping
form me a little bit.
But I would tell you that,
And there's some feedback going on.
Dustin, can you think about it real quick.
Yeah, that's good, can you hear me?
- (mic cracking) I'll
try go somewhere louder.
- We're good.
- It's pretty.
- Better?
- Yeah, a little bit better,
still chopping feedback.
- Can you go on mute?
Can you put yourself on mute?
- So, I think the thing that you need
to think about is, LinkedIn.
And the thing that you
need to think about.
Yeah, Dustin, let's rock him off.
Because I've got my answer anyway.
Donny, thank you for listening.
A, re-watch this
'cause people in the comments
we're talking about hiring you .
And B, it's just exposure.
It's an exposure game.
I do think LinkedIn is a
good place to go as well.
Talk about how you're a voice actor
and what that means for content on social,
and on the ability to really
be the voice of their pre-roll YouTube ad.
I think that's a real shot.
And here's Donny's information.
If anybody wants to jam with him.
I don't know if that's zero for over.
There's an, O or zero.
But you'll figure that out.
All right, let's keep going.
- Garyvee, what's up, Gary. (chuckles)
- What's good, Robby.
- Hey, so, I just had a few
quick couple of questions
I wanted to ask you.
First of all, I love your show by the way.
- I've been watching it
for a couple of years now, thank you.
- Thank you, where are you from?
- Texas, Dallas, Texas, yeah.
So what I wanted to ask you was,
you talked a lot about self-awareness
and like becoming an
entrepreneur and stuff.
And when I was a kid,
I noticed I had a lot of those tendencies.
But I kind of bought into the whole,
you need to be good at
school in order to do well.
So I just like wouldn't hand
like, 14, 18 hours a day into it.
(chuckles) And it was a mistake.
So I was like depressed and happy.
So my question is,
I know you talk, "Look
back when you were a kid,
to see what you're doing."
But what if you've just
struggled with depression
all the time, so you weren't
really doing anything.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- That makes sense at all?
- Of course it makes sense.
Which is why, all the stuff I talk about,
or hypotheses and ideas,
but they don't always fit for
everybody depending on it.
So, what you're referring
to, for everybody's watching,
is a lot of times people at, 20, 21, 22,
even 30 40 are asking me,
"Gary, I don't know my passion."
I always ask them,
"Well, what did you do as a kid?
"Or what do you like?"
But sometimes you don't have to go
as far as what you did as a kid,
it might be, Robby,
what you're doing right now.
I'm a big fan of paying attention
of what people consume.
Like, for example,
I've been so busy with
the all end challenge,
trying to keep the companies along.
Just a lot of shit.
Black lives matter.
There's been so much.
But, in the few minutes
that I've had to myself,
I've either looked up sports cards
and bought them on eBay.
Or have watched wrestling
documentaries on WWE, OTT.
That's a clear indication
of who I am right now,
even of what I like.
- Yeah.
- And begs the debate that,
if I started a podcast
around wrestling cards,
which are, by the way, I genuinely believe
are under priced.
And like have a big opportunity,
that would make me incredibly happy.
Now, I'm wildly happy
doing what I'm doing.
So I won't make that pivot yet.
But I always do wonder,
if I'll ever have a breaking point.
And all the pressure that I have to hold.
And I'm I okay with selling it off
or walking away.
And just doing something simplistic.
Like, garage sailing, or sports cards,
or things of that nature.
I would really look at what
you gravitate towards doing.
Like, what do you watch?
What do you do?
Like, what do you like?
You know, like, what is it?
- I would say--
- Music, sports, video games,
cooking, travel, skiing, you know.
- Video games and
probably fiction writing.
And also I've been reading a lot
about entrepreneurship too.
But I know you've gotta
actually get out there and do it too.
- Well, you gotta fiction write,
and you gotta play video
games or record it.
So there's nothing wrong
with educating yourself
or consuming the push I give
when I'm like, "What you got to do is,
that's the truth."
- Yeah.
- Nothing will happen by
watching my videos unlimited.
You have to do that thing.
There's nothing wrong with consuming.
It's just that,
if you use consuming as the justification
that you're doing,
you tend to get unhappy.
- Right.
- I mean,Robby, you're in a place
where you can start YouTube videos
and Instagram accounts and TikToks,
around video games and fiction writing.
You can literally write the first page
of a fiction story that
you have in your mind,
in the notes app on your phone,
and post that on Instagram
with 12 followers.
And that could be the moment.
It's unlikely, but it could,
- Right, it's true.
- You gotta, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You gotta lean into your interests.
It leads to happiness.
You you're too young to
give up on happiness.
People that are 75,
I'm willing to say you
can give up on happiness.
And what I mean by that is
not giving up on happiness.
I mean, professional happiness.
I would say, "Okay, you're 75, fuck it."
Yes, you're allowed to go
to save your money or whatever.
Hopefully you save some money.
If you wanna go to Florida or Arizona,
and just go off, like cool.
But if you're 52 right now
and you hate your fucking job,
I don't want you to keep doing that.
Because there's another 20 years, likely,
of you working based on what
I'm seeing in the numbers.
Like, fuck, like, fuck all ready.
This is why I don't want
people to buy houses
that are too expensive for them.
I don't want people not to buy houses.
I don't want people to buy
houses that they can't afford.
I don't want people to not buy cars.
I don't want them to buy cars
they can't afford.
I don't want people to not buy jewelry.
I don't want them to buy
jewelry that they can't afford.
I'm buying, fucking,
hundreds of thousand dollars sports cards.
But I can afford it.
That's stupid if you can't afford it.
I want people to drink $6 coffees,
if they can afford it.
I don't want them to
buy it when they can't.
Saving money is incredibly important.
Living within your means
is incredibly important.
And more importantly,
having a job you hate or
doing something you hate
just to pay for stuff.
To make, pretend you're happy.
That's the worst of them all.
- Right, right.
- You've already lived that.
You fucking thought you
had to do something.
It made you unhappy.
And it became a spiral
and you became very unhappy.
- I'm 25 right now. (laughs)
I feel like I'm, 50 sometimes.
- Bro, your super young, bro.
Please promise me, Robby,
that you understand how young you are.
At 25, I was stocking bottles
on shelves in a liquor store
on this exact moment, for real.
Checking in orders.
100%, at this exact moment, when I was 25,
deliveries would come
to Shoppers Discount,
I think that'd be named
to Wine Library by then,
Wine Library, deliveries would come.
10 cases of Dowell's scotch,
five cases of Budweiser,
13 cases of a Sauvignon Blanc I bought.
And I would fucking check in the invoice.
"Okay, we got 13, check, check."
I would sign the invoice.
I would then walk, get it out in truck,
ship it down a conveyor belt,
take one case of the 15, Sauvignon Blanc,
put it on the shelf,
get a little card that I had,
write the review of the
Sauvignon Blanc, put it up,
customer walk in.
"Where's the scotch?"
"Right over here, ma'am," right?
That was my life at 25.
I was a fucking schlepping
at a liquor store.
- That's true.
- So--
- No, no, no.
Stick with me here fucking Robby.
- Okay, okay, all right.
- This is huge.
That's what I was doing at, 21.
- Yep, yep, I've--
- You've unlimited time.
- So if you were to,
'cause I know you worked in a liquor store
and that's actually the second part
I wanted to ask you about was,
with work ethic part,
I have a lot of experience with that.
But where I don't have experience,
is I grew up kinda middle-class.
So that kind of like,
lower-class hustle you always
talk about, so to speak,
I just graduated from college and--
- Listen, listen, a lot of things I say
people think is blanket.
- Right.
- I see things.
But I have highly wealthy friends
that grew up rich, on the upper East side,
with unlimited grinded work ethic.
- Okay.
- I think your work ethic will explode
when you're doing something you love.
For example, I have great work ethic.
But I don't stay up to two
o'clock in the morning,
working on Empathy,
the K-Swiss still, the Vaynermedia.
But I stayed up to two
o'clock in the morning
buying sports cards the other night.
Because my passion was
off the fucking charts.
- Okay, okay.
- I think most people are not lazy.
I think they're doing
something they don't like.
I'm unbelievably lazy in school.
I'm unbelievably lazy,
if you asked me to hang six
pictures up in an apartment.
I can work for 18 hours
straight when I love it.
Work ethic, oftentimes, maps to the thing.
I think too many people deem themselves
as not ambitious and lazy,
when in reality,
it's because they don't
like what they're doing.
- Right, right, so would you,
if you just got a job,
or I just graduated from college
with a license in
speech-language pathology.
- Do you wanna do that?
- (laughs) No, no, no.
I don't at all.
- You don't.
So my question, but would you,
in order to make money to
kinda support yourself,
I mean that, I'm kind of limited to taxes
- Fair enough, there's two
ways to think about it.
One, and obviously let's take
COVID out of the equation
a year from now, hopefully.
So, you know what I mean?
Obviously those are some variables.
- Yep.
- One, you live really humbly.
AKA, at your parents house,
at a girlfriend, boyfriend's house.
I don't know what your situation is.
Or, what six homeys in a shithole.
- Yeah.
- Then it allows you to go real ham,
if you're fucking caught,
if you're paying, $100
dollars a month in rent,
because you have six other roommates
and you fucking gonna sleep on the couch,
it all depends on where you're at.
You know, you can get
a speech pathology job,
and then, my concern with that is,
is that you then live a lifestyle
based on that salary.
Which never lets you really save
and go on to the other thing.
You could get a speech pathology job
and live like shit.
So you save like a fucker.
And you could save for
two years worth of living.
And then you go and jump at, 28.
- Right.
- I'm a little bit more
into the happiness.
Even those three years saving kinda suck.
Even when you have this great mission.
But there's a million different examples.
I mean, there's 25 year olds
that have two children
and have responsibilities,
and can't live in a shithole
'cause they're scared for their children.
And there's a million scenarios out there.
But for you,
Where do you live at?
- I've no debt.
I'm in Dallas right now.
I've no debt or anything.
My parents took care of it.
So I'm just thinking,
should I just park up somewhere
(laughs) and like become
a bartender or something.
Like, I don't know.
- First of all, you should
kiss your parents on the face
and thank them.
Because no debt's a monster.
- Absolutely.
- I think you should start
creating on the internet
to get a taste, if there's
anything you'd like.
If your entrepreneurial tendencies
were around flipping and selling,
buying and selling stuff,
you should give that thought.
If it was more about like
macro entrepreneurship.
'Cause there's a difference between
operations entrepreneurship,
sales entrepreneurship.
Sales entrepreneurship
is an incredible trait.
'Cause it always lets you breathe.
'Cause selling lets you breath, you know.
So, I think that's what
you have to think about.
- Okay, okay, now it's much fun.
The idea kind of wanting
to go my own way side
versus more of the strict selling side.
Selling is one of the
skills I've had to work
kind of to build up.
- I mean, there's also partnerships.
You have any really good friends
who you might wanna team up with?
That's always a fun thing to think about.
Like if I said to you right now,
you have to start a business.
You have to, it's like the rule,
new mandated law.
What would you do?
- Probably try to become a writer.
That's where my talent is.
So, maybe dive into that.
- I love that.
Bro, you have to start writing.
Do you write?
Like, do you put out your
writing in the world?
- No, I don't.
I need to think of a way to do.
I've heard like Wattpad
and stuff like that.
But beyond that, I don't really know.
- Wattpad's incredible.
Wattpad for everybody, W-A-T-T pad.
But I also think Instagram's incredible.
I think writing stuff
on, like I said, on notes
and just posting it.
I think then taking that
and making a YouTube video
where you read the story, you know.
Fiction right?
- Fiction, fiction, yep.
- Listen to me and listen to me good.
You need to seriously consider
just writing the first 10 pages
of a make-pretend story.
Putting them out on Instagram,
reading them on YouTube,
putting them out on TikTok.
I would do that for a year.
And see if anything clicked. (snaps)
You might have the next "Harry Potter"
or fucking "Star Wars" in you,
but you don't even know.
But by putting it out there,
you might see people jump on it.
Start, you know,
Reddit has some great communities
where you can start to make pretend land.
Bro, you gotta go, Robby.
You gotta eliminate the
insecurity of feedback.
Of like, remember I think it's great.
And then everybody else
that says it sucks,
tell them to DM me.
And I'll tell him to go fuck themselves.
(laughs)
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You gotta put it out.
- I've been really indecisive
and negative, Gary.
But you've helped it a lot, thank you.
- What did you say Rob?
- Oh, I've been really
indecisive and negative
for a lot of time.
But you've helped that a lot.
So, thank you.
You've given me a lot of positivity.
- I appreciate that.
Why do you think that?
Because I wanna learn from your feedback.
Because I wanna do more of it.
'cause it's the greatest feeling
to bring that kind of value to somebody.
Like, what clicked for you?
- During, I would say growing up
making nothing but A's.
Even though a lot of people
like, with my disabilities,
told me I would make; C's, D's, fails,
stuff like that.
It was a lot of knowledge that--
- And the disabilities were what?
Like dyslexia, like common, like cliche.
- ADHD, auditory processing,
slow processing speed, all that.
Sort of an amalgamation of things
with the depression, so, yeah.
- And did that make you feel inferior?
- It made me attach
myself worth to praise.
So like, A's awards.
Because that was all I ever,
I mean, I even did
certain during lunch, so,
- You were showing them, you showed them.
See, I can.
- Right, 'cause I had the ambition.
And that was the direction
I was sort of given the go.
- And what did your parents think of that?
- I think they're starting
to realize more and more
that school, never was for me.
My mom's the very type, A, accountant.
Like go make A's stuff like, yeah.
- Yup, yup, I understand.
Listen, so anyway, I apologize.
So what do you think
really clicked for you?
- With your videos?
- Mmmh.
- Just your very positive nature of,
you can go out, do
anything, just tell people.
You're just very frank
that you have to live for you.
And a lot of ways.
And it was a way that came
across as genuine, yeah.
- And what I don't think
people understand is,
when you go to that level of selfishness,
there's an incredible ability
to become selfless.
Me, making myself happy,
over this whole process,
now allows me to be the man that I am,
that sits here for an hour every morning,
desperately wanting for you to be happy,
with no interest or expectation
for anything in return.
Because it comes out of gratitude
that I've navigated to this place.
And I want it for everybody else.
And if I'd not done that
I would be needing, not giving.
- Right.
- Had I not gone that route
and thought that I needed
everybody else's affirmation to live.
I'd still be grabbing for that right now.
And I'd have no opportunity to give.
It's the person that's the happiest
that is able to give.
It's the same reason that all the trolling
and negativity online.
I feel bad for those people.
'Cause they're in a bad place.
- Yeah.
- Of course you can't be
compassionate or nice.
You're not happy.
- That's true, absolutely true.
- The communication style and
the format it just kind of,
there was a practicality
to the way that I was describing it
that felt real to you.
- Yeah, and also you're resonate with,
school isn't the only way.
And I always felt out of place in school
even though that's where
I spend all my time.
'Cause I just thought,
well, that's the way you do things and,
- Yeah, well listen,
I wish you nothing but good, Robby.
Please do me a favor, please.
I have a weird feeling about this.
And really I'm probably just
being selfish right now.
Because when you're on fucking Kobe
or talking about your book.
You're gonna be like, "Big
shout out to Garryvee."
(laughs)
I really think you should write,
three to five pages.
How many different stories,
do you think you have in your head?
- Really good ones, maybe three.
- How many solid ones?
- About three or five.
- How many, okay one's.
- About 10. (chuckles)
- I want you to put out all, 10.
10 pages of each on the internet for free.
And watch your fucking life change.
Here's the, I'm giving
you the straight formula.
I rarely do this.
As you know, I talk more.
I need you to write the first 10 pages
of each of those stories,
all 10, not three.
When you loose the high of this moment,
I don't need you to go to
actually the only ones good.
No, no, all 10.
Because what you think is just okay,
might be the fucking one.
- That's true.
- 'Cause you don't get to decide.
They get to decide, got it.
I want you to write the
first 10 pages for all 10.
I assume in the way
that it fits in an Instagram post.
That's probably, 20 to
five posts per story
to get to 10 pages worth.
I don't really know the math.
On this write 30 posts, 15 posts.
You know what I mean, right?
Like literally, you know, like part.
And don't do a carousel.
This way you can do like four posts a day.
One of 10, "It was an
early Wednesday morning."
Like literally, name it.
And I want you to do that.
Then I want you to read it on YouTube.
Just like this, face to camera, read it.
That's your YouTube content.
And then I want you to figure
out some sort of version
of one of the two on TikTok.
I want you posting on all three of those,
and add Twitter to that,
and do the same thing
you're doing on Instagram.
I want you to do that every day
for the next three months of COVID.
I'm telling you it can change your life.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You will be blown away, Robby.
By the random emails
that you will get or DMs.
I don't think it's
crazy that you're crying
on Tea With Garyvee, on October 9th.
Because you signed a book deal
about your fucking fantasy land book.
I really believe this.
- I believe it too.
- And you're gonna be happy doing it.
It's way more fun than bartending.
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah,
that's definitely true.
- Just do it, Robby.
Just fucking do it, please.
- I will.
- What's your handle on Instagram?
- I have no Instagram right now.
I have no public
Instagram right now, yeah.
- Right, you're gonna do all that.
Robby, listen to me.
Please, don't let this moment pass.
Please set up those accounts.
Don't be scared.
Start the process of getting comfortable
with not meeting affirmation.
Start getting comfortable
with the person that
leaves a comment that says,
"This is dorky."
Start getting comfortable
with the person coming along
that watches this show,
but unfortunately is still
hurt inside themselves.
And comes and says, "I saw you in Garyvee.
"You're not gonna make
it, the story's stupid."
Start getting comfortable with that.
Start letting that feed you.
Start letting that get you excited.
That's them, they're down, not you.
- Get that inside.
God, I hope I can help
people like you. (laughs)
- I get excited when people say I'm shit.
Or that I'm gonna fall.
Or, "That you suck."
Or, "You're overrated."
Or, "I don't get why people like him."
Or, "He's bad."
I get excited.
It actually feeds the fuck out of me.
- Drives you.
- They're confused, they
think they're tearing me down.
They're fucking feeding me.
You can't beat something
that's unbeatable.
- That's true, that's very true, Gary.
- Please use this, okay brother.
I really weirdly believe
something good is gonna,
I weirdly, genuinely my bones.
And my bones are right
more often than not.
I think something good
is going to happen, man.
Please, can you please promise
you'll deliver on this?
I really think you'll be happy.
Even if nothing crazy happens.
You're gonna feel so good
at the end of these three months.
- I wIll.
- I believe you.
- I promise you, man.
- I love you pal.
- I'll contact you
if anything happens.
- Please do, thank you.
That's it.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, Robby.
This was a real show.
- Yeah.
- This was like a real fucking show.
- Yeah, I really, heavy
rocked with Robby allot.
- You did?
- Yeah, I mean, first, just not knowing
how young he is at, 25.
Like everyone thinks they're so old.
And even I felt that when I was, 25.
Like, "Oh crap, I gotta
get my life together
in five years or whatever."
And just people don't
realize how young they are.
Like, it's just, frustrating. (laughs)
Hearing it all the time
from, 20 year olds.
I'm like, "You don't
realize how young you are."
- That's why we do this every day.
Speaking of everyday,
we'll be back tomorrow.
Please take the URL that
you're watching right now.
If you're on Twitter, or
Facebook, or LinkedIn.
Please share this right now.
Tell everybody to join
tomorrow, 9:00 a.m..
And please set up Twitter with
your review of today's show.
Please, @garyvee on Twitter.
Also today's Winetext is, bonkers.
If you're a wine drinker, winetext.com.
Some of you're sleeping on that.
And sports cards.
Make sure you watch or
listen to the last show.
And there's a couple of
long form videos of me
on YouTube around it.
It's really fun.
Can be really, really good.
Especially if you're a
gambler, and sports gambler.
I think you should shift your energy
or a consider it.
I appreciate you, I'll
see you tomorrow, peace.